let's go to our caller from the 2:05
area code who's calling today from 2:05
David this is John and uncle in
Tennessee hey John what's up so I got a
question for you regarding Fox News and
just I guess progressive and pressive
voices going on Fox News segments I mean
I understand that you've done that a
handful of times I've done it all right
twice you got it twice yeah this is more
related to I guess a recently crystal
ball and you know other folks like E and
sorry like your regular radio and I
heard you say crystal ball and I don't
know who else you mentioned I think
Michael Tracy and Greenwald you know
they really go on Tucker Carlson or Sean
Hannity I just need to get your take on
if you believe that's helpful for the
progressives or if you think it's
harmful or if they're really just kind
of playing into maybe Tucker or Sean's
mo as it stands for that show I have not
seen any of those appearances so the
devil is in the details and what matters
is what is the appearance like Tucker
Carlson is an expert at framing up
conversations in a way that is
ultimately beneficial to his worldview
which is the sort of non interventionist
right-wing with a streak of at least
claimed anti elitism that whether it's
real or not I don't know I mean
certainly Tucker is is one of the elites
in a sense I've not seen any of those
appearances I think generally
progressives going on Fox News is
perfectly fine I've done it if you're
well prepared and if you can sort of
take control of the framing and do a
good job in espousing your view not in a
way where you get kind of pushed into a
corner and used as a useful idiot I
think it's great to go on Fox News it
doesn't always work that way but again
the three appearances you mentioned I
don't even know all the people you
mentioned I don't know who who Michael
the Michael person you mentioned is and
I haven't seen them so I wouldn't be
able to say for sure but in
ideologically I have no problem with
progressives going on fox news if
they're well prepared to do it doctor
all right thank you all right thank you
for the call great to hear from you